okay so you think one piece is long okay
and it is long yes and so is Detective
Conan but let's give it up for one of
the true Kings of the manga industry
Hajime no IPO if you haven't heard of it
look it up because it has been running
continuously without pause and to this
day since
1989. that's nearly 35 years I mean can
you imagine writing anything or a story
with characters every single week for 35
years straight when Hajime no ipo's
author doji morikawa started writing the
manga the Cold War was still ongoing the
Tiananmen Square massacre happened the
year he started the manga the very first
Game Boy Yes you know the one that
needed that light clicked onto the back
around 7pm it had only just been
released I just it is hard to overstate
how insane of a feat it is for one
single person to be writing this same
singular story uninterrupted for that
long